i don't know if you know this or not but
i am now a greenie i am now an
environmentalist you know why really
because i heard of offset carbon credits
market courtesy of our good friend
robert kiyosaki yeah now i understand
why so many people are like suddenly
becoming environmentally aware and they
want to invest in green projects yes
because the market that's developing and
offset uh carbon credits right now that
everyone in the world has to play by
yeah
do you think you're gonna is there any
is that lucrative is that a good feature
i'm sure it is it's just not a game that
i play
because to me
you're angel investing
and i i don't like to do that i you know
where's the cash flow i like to
another kind of saying i have that may
be helpful to the viewers
is i always want to buy a dollar for 50
cents
i never want to buy a dollar for three
dollars hoping it goes to five dollars
so when you're dealing with carbon
credits and whatnot you know what's the
market is it cheap i don't know i i
can't price it who are you going to sell
it to berkshire hathaway yeah it's it's
yeah i'm sure there's firs people who
are experts in that i'm sure there's a
massive opportunity
that's just not the type of game i play
i like to
it's got strong cash flows and wait for
panic to buy that cash that dollar worth
of cash flow for 50 cents that's what
that i mean and that's the the panic
side of that is actually the the the
primary element of that market is
because what happens is you buy those
credits in the beginning of the year
nobody needs them and you're sitting on
top of them until tax season comes back
around and then you sell the
theoretically sell those
offset carbon credits to companies who
are like it's more expensive for them to
actually initiate these environmental
things than it is to just simply go buy
credits on the open market that you now
have a hold of and so like right around
october november right before you know
that it flips over the the year flips
over now you sell them at a profit
that's the idea yeah let me give you an
example a specific example for your
viewers uh just based on what has
happened in the last couple days altria
so the cigarette maker
okay they just got nailed
some governing board banned those jewel
yeah joule's been officially exactly
yeah so austria altria takes a massive
hit okay i don't know if it's down 10 15
which is big for that stock because it
doesn't move much
well this is panic in the market so what
the market's not realizing is that
you've got india you've got china you've
got the emerging markets that over the
long term as people go from very very
poor
into the middle class they consume more
things that are unhealthy they consume
more sugar
they consume more alcohol red meat red
meat they smoke more cigarettes maybe
not in india though
so sure you might have the the the
decrease in demand for joule but you
long term you've got a lot of tailwind
there but even if demand stays the same
so what because of this price drop
because the panic now all of a sudden
the dividend yield goes up to almost 9
it's like 8.2 8.3 so you can buy which
by the way you're buying it a company
that historically has always almost
always increased their dividend that is
one of the safest dividends you can get
so that's an example of buying a dollar
for 50 cents based on some short-term
panic and putting that in that 80
percent of your portfolio that's going
to pay you to own it so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]